I forwarded my recent blood work to you.
There are several issues, but the one I see right away
that I just can't understand are my high cholesterol numbers.
I'm lowered.
How can this be?
How can I have worse numbers than the month of my diagnosis
before I started eating such a good whole food plant-based diet?
I gave blood for this test immediately, followed five day fast.
I broke my fast after the draw, during which time I also
had COVID.
I went for the test as soon as I was able after quarantine.
Could that affect my cholesterol numbers?
I don't think having a viral infection of any kind
would affect your cholesterol numbers.
What can, so let's talk about what can increase a person's
cholesterol numbers?
What is cholesterol?
So cholesterol is a fact that is made in your liver.
So, to be honest, 97% at least of your circulating cholesterol
in your blood is made in your liver.
It's not from your diet.
So can diet affect cholesterol?
Well, yes, if I eat a diet that damages my liver,
like full of chemicals and additives and flavorings and toxins,
that's going to put a lot of stress on my liver.
And I will actually create more cholesterol
in order to help lubricate my liver among other things.
So I will have an elevated cholesterol.
So what else could cause an elevated cholesterol?
I'm not eating that kind of stuff.
I've cleaned up this person saying they've
cleaned up their diets, they're eating a whole food diet.
They're doing so many things right.
How in the world could I have elevated cholesterol?
Well, there's other reasons as well.
So, first of all, we have to define what elevated cholesterol is.
When I went to school, of course, I'm an old guy,
but when I went to school, 225 was a normal cholesterol level.
And anything above 225 was considered elevated cholesterol.
Then it dropped out to 200.
Then it dropped out to 180.
Well, why is that?
Because 225 is dangerous now?
No, I don't think so.
I think it's because they have this wonderful drug
where they make $80 million a year selling
that can lower your cholesterol levels.
Well, it's a wonderful drug to lower your cholesterol levels,
but it damages your liver and causes all sorts of problems.
So you don't want to be a limiter or a statin drug, in my opinion.
Now, is there a time that that might be appropriate
if a person's cholesterol is over 300 or 400 or something
like that?
Well, maybe if you can't deal with it with some natural means.
There are some natural cholesterol lower rate things
that I'm pretty sure I wrote multiple blog posts on this.
So do look in the blog up there at the thing
about cholesterol levels.
But so elevated cholesterol can be,
so you do want to look at possibly doing some liver cleansing,
ask yourself, first of all, is it way over 250?
Is it over 300?
To me, if you have a cholesterol of 280,
it's still not something that you should really be concerned with.
If you have a cholesterol of 325, then maybe, yeah,
then I think you need to start making some interventions.
And normally, I would start with dietary interventions,
which doesn't have to be done in this case,
but you could do some other natural things
to help with decreasing cholesterol.
I don't think having COVID is going
to really affect cholesterol levels very much.
Possibly fasting, I have to look that up
whether fasting can increase cholesterol for a short time.
It don't have the answer to that.
I will look after tomorrow or something
to make sure that I've updated that blog post
about cholesterol.
This is a product by a fourth of a lecture
called Lipitor, that was very good at motoring cholesterol.
That was very beneficial for people
to keep a healthy cholesterol level.